va présenter cette thématique est
extrême gentillesse des gens
il avait 70 spectacles et de la
communication aux autres et ceci c'est
notre r&d qu'augmenter les moments
historiques les écoles ce livre et
c'était un succès extraordinaire parce
que les gens découvrent et avec lui dont
seulement une histoire des cultures
fauché un formidable conteur c'est l
ambassadeur de la touraine l'ambassadeur
d'abord culturel c'est un personnage
historique un personnage je dirais
presque portant hors norme
il est mort dans un accident de voiture
il n'avait pas son permis de conduire
parce que il trouvait que c'était est
pas nécessaire pour bien vivre et il
savait s'arrêter sur des choses des
événements d ce qui fait le côté
extraordinaire qui nous semble ordinaire
et qui pour lui est extraordinaire et et
je crois que c'est ça un vrai artiste je
garde de mon accent pris le souvenir de
quelqu'un qui avait une capacité assez
extraordinaire à faire vivre mes sujets
dont il parlait c'est à dire qu' il
était tellement fantasque tellement
enthousiaste tellement plein de son
sujet qu'il devenait son sujet quand il
écrivait un livre sur léonard de vinci
il est elle narre de vinci quand c'était
un livre sur lui aux il était louis 11
et donc sur un plateau de télévision
il avait cette capacité de vulgarisation
c'est à dire l'art de choisir l'anecdote
qui fait que le téléspectateur va tendre
l'oreille va tout à coup avoir envie de
connaître ce personnage a été très
fidèle en amitié comme c'est pas tout le
temps et je me souviens de fait
d'apparition lors d'événements familiaux
du mariage une de mes filles où ils
avaient ils avaient enchanté pour les
convives
il aimait beaucoup la vie il aimait
intégralement il l'est mais de façon
comme ici dans tiff est toujours à ses
personnages j'avais il y avait un peu de
notre balzac en lui et non à cinq ans à
50 ans d'avoir trop bien vécu et tout
était intense avec et tout était sans
limites avec avec gonzague que ce soit
les fêtes nocturnes les soirées les
dîners la dégustation alors ne
s'arrêtait pas comme moi dans le détail
il était voilà il était davantage une
espèce de globalité d'euphorie de la vie
permanente grosses productions
littéraires peut-être part d'un niveau
il était plus écrivant que tu écrives h
10 avec beaucoup d'affection